Hey.
Oh!
Wait, wait.
Jolly!
Ram Raja.
I swear I saw the news.
Wait, what news?
Extremely savage.
Genuinely, I wish you nothing but the best for your future.
The news, of course, that you smell.
Got him.
Stop!
Stop it!
Wait, oh gosh.
There's another super chat.
I'm just gonna scroll up.
Sorry, you're gonna have to listen to it.
I haven't even done my intro!
You guys are sending things!
All I said was hey!
Did someone say Devil May Cry 4?
Because that's my thang.
This is your thang then.
This is your thang.
Do I select applicant only for the Aqua Finale International Lottery?
Or one accompanying person and hope to find someone else to come along?
Oh, I think you should try the one accompanying...
Actually, I don't know.
Will you have a better chance of being a solo seat or double seats?
I think you should do the solo.
Fuck Nicholas!
Anyway, let me do my intro, you guys.
Let me do my intro.
Devil Minky Cry.
Hello, welcome back to Devil May Cry 4.
Wake up block!
Thank you so much for the donation!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
DMC!
DMC, baby!
So, for people watching the VOD, you might be watching the VOD because of the time change.
And if that's the case, thank you for watching the VOD!
I'm sorry about the time change.
I got asked about something tonight.
It was last minute.
It was literally, I think, like the day after I posted my schedule.
And I could not say no.
So, the time has come and so has Minty!
I will not say what it is related to for...
I don't know if it's a surprise or anything.
I've been possessed for three months.
Congrats on headlining Lollapalooza.
I don't even know what that is.
Okay, for those who don't know, someone made like an edit of my name on this music festival thing.
The Lollapalooza.
I don't even...
It was Tia, right?
And I saw my name on that and I was like, whoa, what is this?
What did I sign up for?
But I don't...
Lollapalooza.
Can I get a sneak peek of what's happening on Sunday so I can prepare for my FOMO arc?
Watch Mufasa or whatever movie you want on the plane with Power Pro Minto.
I don't get the Minto plush until right after I leave.
No!
Oh, actually, Sunday.
I had an idea for something, but I don't have enough time to do it.
So I'm actually moving it.
Sunday will instead be like 10 hours of dredge.
I hope you guys don't mind.
I had an idea, but things have been like...
Things have been like...
Things last minute.
People contacting me for meetings and things of the such and like.
So I've been like...
And then also other things like taking care...
Like I've been having to go do stuff taking care of my car.
And my sink broke.
With this other stuff that I've had to...
Stuff with my cats I've had to take care of.
So it's just like...
I've been being pulled every which way.
Yeah, busy busy.
Not just with the stream stuff, but also with other things.
So I've been like...
So much, so much.
I have a favorite shape.
I'm in love with the shape of you.
Only 10 hours.
She says 10 hours of dredge like it's a bad thing.
Yeah, I'm gonna start early like probably around this time.
And then just play until I can't play no more.
Friendship.
Friend.
Minky never cry.
Sorry.
Every time you see this happening, it's me scrolling on...
With my mouse.
Like that.
You've been very mature.
I've been very mature.
Like, like, like a wine.
Mmm, Devil May Scroll.
I too go hoo-ha-hee-ha when things go bad at work.
Are you...
Are you giving birth at work?
Oh, that's the breathing.
That's the breathing when they say to give birth, no?
What kind of job do you have?
Take care of yourself, boss.
Thank you.
How do you know that?
Is that not just the thing that people say?
Like, when you give birth, go hee-hoo-ha, hee-hoo-ha.
Everyone knows that.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Minky bait.
Jason breathing on Friday the 13th.
Ch -ch-ch-ch.
Thank you, thanks for the five gift card.
Thank you.
Sound Jason Voorhees makes.
Is it?
No, he goes...
Why is everyone saying different things?
Some people are saying ki-ki, some people are saying la-la, some people are saying ha-ha.
It's like we're all laughing different ways.
Ki-ki-ki-ki-ki-ki.
Ha-ha.
But
yeah, welcome back to Devil May Cry.
Last time we ended, um, uh, beat the first, uh, beat our first boss.
We beat our first boss.
Oh, sorry, I thought my cat was in here.
And we, uh, that was it.
Ki-ki or a booba.
Second boss.
What was the first boss?
What's the first boss?
The five...
Oh, right!
Oh my gosh, he was so easy.
I like, totally forgot about that.
I didn't have to use a health or anything on that guy.
I'm just...
Wow, I completely forgot about him!
Oops.
Extra cool.
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Thank you so much!
Oh, oopsie.
I forgot about him.
Yeah, we beat a second boss.
Oh my gosh!
Wow, and here I was feeling kind of bad.
I was like, man...
I only beat one boss last stream.
Kind of bad.
You use the health thing.
No, I didn't.
That's right.
Also, I want to say some stuff.
Because I saw comments of people...
Being like, um...
Hey, Minto, don't feel bad that you don't rev.
Because honestly, um...
It's...
It's, you know, it's good to know.
But...
Um...
That some people, like, didn't really get good at it and stuff.
Until, like, multiple playthroughs.
So...
So, you know, I'll keep trying.
But I'm not gonna beat myself up over not using it.
I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna beat myself up over using it.
But if you want to remind me...
Just try not to, like, spam remind me.
If you don't mind.
But if you want to be like...
By the way, Minto, you could rev.
Be like, oh yeah.
I could do that sometimes.
But there are some things...
Because there's new controls...
We got the grabby grabs last time too.
That's, like, a core mechanical.
Grabby grab.
Um...
And I just kind of have to remember how to combo things.
And I don't remember how to fight.
I'm gonna have to remember how to fight.
Oh, ow.
You can press Alt F4 to beat the game immediately.
Oh my gosh.
You're so right.
Secret codes.
That's the Capcom code.
You know how there's the Konami code?
The Capcom code is Alt F4 on your game.
But yeah.
Limit one rev reminder per 15 minutes, right?
Um, yeah.
So, you know, I'm not gonna be perfect at the game.
It's my first time playing it.
And first time using a lot of these new controls.
So just be patient with me while I learn the game.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Hmm.
Works on more than just Capcom.
It's been adopted as a universal code.
Probably.
All good, Mito.
Thank you.
Enjoy the game first.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Anyway, are we ready to get back into it?
I've yapped.
I've yapped for like 15 minutes.
Am I lagging?
Maybe it's okay.
Okay, let's go.
Devil may cry.
Here we are.
Devil hunter.
And we just beat that guy.
Oh, shall we try the other outfit?
Since I did this outfit before.
Shall we try this one with our little...
Do you think they can grab the scarf?
Hello, Mito.
Hello, Brandon.
Yeah, we should try it.
Okay, why not, why not?
I thought it would be like how, you know, if you...
Oh.
Oh, I was like, why are you...
I already got out.
I already got out too.
Holy moly loud.
Hold on, I'm gonna go fix that.
Why is it so loud?
Thank you so much, Salken.
Oh my goodness.
Have you ever played Sly Cooper games?
I haven't.
Would you consider trying them?
Maybe.
There's a sexy fox lady that chases him.
I see.
Hold on, I'm gonna go fix this...
The sound on this thing real quick.
I don't know why it's so loud.
Hold on one moment.
Oh, it's at like 100% volume.
When did that happen?
Save.
Okay.
That should be good.
That should be better.
Actually, I'm gonna turn it down.
Just leave it a little bit more just in case.
I can always turn it up.
Minto, I want to talk about severance.
Oh my gosh, me too.
Oh my gosh, Mogu messaged me this morning and was just like...
Minto, I have no one else to talk about severance with.
Nobody's watching it.
I was like...
Because I don't want to...
So for those who don't know, the season 2 finale aired last night and it was like...
I don't want to talk about it because there's probably so many people that haven't watched it.
So I'm also just been like...
Who do I talk about with severance?
I can talk about with Mogu.
Severance is a TV show.
It's really good.
It's really, really good.
It's...
I don't want to get too much into it now because we're about to start the game, but...
Obtain the winged talisman.
What do I have?
Let's see.
What do we have?
Oh, I have...
I have 1100.
Nice.
So we could get...
Okay, so let me actually look at these because...
Okay.
Why, why then?
Why, why, why, why?
And why, why?
Mid-air.
Why, why?
Then a pause and then a why?
Yesterday was my birthday, but I didn't want to bother between...
Between on or after the collab.
Could I ask you for a song, please?
Of course!
Lerian is how I say her name.
I hope so.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Lerian.
Chuu!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday!
Thank you, thank you.
Testing.
Oh, that one wasn't loud.
It was the...
It was the sponge vibe that was loud.
Thank you!
Alternate outfit that you have Nero in is based on his prototype design.
It was originally meant to be named Rodin.
The sculptor and...
He was supposed to be like a Sherlock Holmes character.
Sipping tea as he...
Oh, I'm so glad they changed him.
He was supposed to be Brash.
Maybe we get Streak 2?
Maybe Streak 2 would be good.
Or, was there anything I was saving up for?
Snatch.
We could do the snatch.
Snatch is...
Wait, what?
Oh, air hike!
Air hike is what I was saving up for.
Do you have air hike?
I don't yet.
Okay, okay, okay.
Saving up, saving up.
Whoa!
I could get rid of some stuff.
I mean, I could get rid of some things.
I don't have that many things, though.
I haven't even...
Bought any, like, charge shot stuff.
Big snatch, though.
I know!
I don't have enough for that, even.
Oh!
Oh, I accidentally pressed...
I pressed...
Oh my gosh, sometimes...
Sometimes I get into, like, Japanese game brand...
where X...
on, like, a PlayStation controller...
is back.
That would have been so bad.
And items.
I can't afford another blorb.
So we'll save up for that, as well.
I'm good.
Mission starter!
Yeah, X and O are swapped.
Oh, look at us!
We're so different.
War, war, so...
Uh, what, what, what, what is the mission again?
So we just did the Coliseum, no?
Ooh.
Is his hair even different?
Boy looks so bruh-ish.
40 minutes.
Friend or foe?
Probably foe.
If it's Devil May Cry, probably.
Oh, here comes the battle music.
Oh no, what is this thing?
Ah!
Um, I can't...
The camera angle is really bad.
Wait, it's a...
Hold on.
Sorry, I forgot.
This...
Why, why?
Why, why, why?
Oh, no.
I'm an idiot.
Why?
Pause, why?
Sorry, I just wanted...
But there is this one.
Why, why, why?
That's what I was thinking of.
Guns work best against these enemies, do they?
Guns and grabs.
Grab is...
Oh!
Oh.
Oh my god!
What the hell is this thing?
Ew, it turned into a lizard!
Bug.
What is this?
Oh my god!
I wish I could grab him again.
Ouch!
Wait.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, it's disgusting!
Wait.
Thank you, though, for the tip about grabbing him.
I'm trying.
Oh.
Come on, Dante.
Come on.
Oh, shoot.
Grab him.
Ouch!
Come here.
Air grab!
There we go.
OK.
Oh, I said Dante?
My bad.
The force of habit.
The force of habit again!
Sorry, Nero.
After obtaining a Rusalka corpse, entering certain areas will cause the devil bringer to be tinged with glowing light.
When this light is visible, succumb to its call and search for nearby items or secret missions.
OK, I'm searching.
Wait, I'm searching.
I'm searching.
These are kind of freaky, no?
These are kind of freaky.
I will destroy everything.
I'm just search...
Searching for stuff.
A little secret sensor.
How cute!
Um, is it...
This doesn't seem to be glowing.
Am I stupid?
It doesn't seem...
Is it glowing more than usual?
I don't think I've ever paid attention to what his arm looked like.
We're farming some rorbs right quick.
Oh!
Oh, now it's glowing.
There we go.
That's a secret mission.
I see.
I learned.
It's pretty obvious what happened.
I see now.
Just destroy everything.
I hate landscaping!
I want an open world layout!
Oh, I can destroy these too.
Nice.
Oh, nice!
Some grorbs.
This is great farming!
Oh.
Healthy Minta.
I'm as strong and healthy as an ox.
Look, they even give us a time statue so that we can...
Get lots of rorbs and then shop, baby, shop.
I wonder what the secret mission is.
Shall we check it out?
Wait.
I thought it glowed, but...
I thought...
Wait, it is glowing.
Oh?
Wait,
there's another one.
I can't get up there though.
Secret rorbs.
Oh, right there!
Oh my gosh.
The secret mission is extremely hard.
I'm really...
Not good with the challenge stuff.
I know you guys know that though.
But that's okay.
We're here for the fun of the game, not the challenge of the game.
Well, it was just a little bit of a challenge, but...
Let's see what it is.
It is...
Raise your stylish ranking without using attacks?
Like, just dodge only?
Dodging and taunting?
That sounds scary.
Okay.
Oops.
All right.
I'm a professional break stuff.
More?
Or is it below?
I must be hinting the thing up below, right?
Oh, this is gonna drive me insane now.
I'm gonna be like, where's the secrets?
This is gonna drive me insane.
Yeah, I really did just say nope.
Okay.
Let's go.
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
It's this guy.
Yeah.
Oh, man.
Oh, wait.
It's a Y.
Y.
I messed up.
Oh, there's more than one of them.
Oh, I wish I got the other guy.
That'd be insane, right?
Oh, maybe it did.
Why?
No, it's...
Oh, I did it.
Hahaha.
I can do it when I'm not panicking.
Why?
Oh.
I'm destroying the foundation of this home.
Okay.
I guess we're good.
Wait, is it glowing?
Was I crazy?
It is glowing.
To what?
It's glowing here.
Oh.
Oh, my gosh.
How many secret missions have we missed?
Why, Victor?
Why?
Puppet master, manipulate the gyro blades and raise everything.
You guys think I can do this one?
This one is easy.
I feel like it sounds...
This one is doable.
We could try.
How do I...
Wait, um...
There was...
Oh, there's a time limit.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Uh, oh, it was...
Oh, shoot.
Uh...
Oh.
There was like a way that I can...
Oh, hold on.
How do I...
Wait, we got, uh...
Uh...
It was a...
It was...
I have to like...
Oh, I...
I activate it and then I cut it with the sword and then I B, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I remember now.
Sorry about that.
Run!
Is there anything down here?
Okay, doesn't seem like it.
This is literally just what we did before, no?
Is it wanting me to...
What does raise everything mean?
We got one out of five, so...
Go!
Did I miss one?
Oh, wait.
I got something.
What did I get?
Oh!
Oh, it's the blue things!
Ah!
Wait.
I'm gonna restart.
Actually, it won't let me.
Ah!
I see, I see, I see.
Okay, okay.
It's the blue things.
Ah, okay.
Oh, this one might be tricky.
Okay, so there's two here and then there's the one.
I don't know if I can make it though.
I don't think I can make it.
I only have 20 seconds left.
That's okay though.
Yeah, not this run, but that's okay.
I was learning what it meant.
There we go.
Oh, see?
Okay.
Maybe we can...
I'm getting orbs at least.
Do I get to keep these?
Failed.
Yeah.
We'll get them next time.
Okay, this one looks doable.
Oh, sorry.
I keep pressing Y action and not...
Not...
Action, action.
Okay.
It's a slow way to farm.
There we go.
Number one.
Okay.
Please don't go too far.
Where are you?
Oh, it went too far.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, no, no, no.
Okay, it went down the hallway.
Good enough, good enough.
Okay, world record pace, baby.
Probably.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm gonna need it to bounce off.
There we go.
Nice.
Okay.
Yeah.
How far did that go, actually?
I might have just screwed myself a little bit.
Yeah, just a little bit.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
Um, I need the camera to change, please.
Camera to change, please.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh, perfect.
Please.
Oh, please.
Please, please, please.
Please.
Oh.
Yeah!
Oh, that was so lucky.
That was so lucky, baby.
Hold on, let's farm our rorbs a little bit before we leave.
Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
18 seconds left.
Not even sweating?
No.
I didn't sweat.
I wasn't worried even a little bit.
Get all of our money, baby.
I like how there's just these in the way.
All right.
Good mission, guys.
The one secret mission I could do.
Are these repeatable?
I'm not sure.
Any experts in chat?
One blorb fragment.
But you won't get the blorbs.
Ah, I see, I see.
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
Ouch.
Ouch!
Oh, that guy had just one hit left.
That's so funny.
Where did you come from?
I think I need to be locked on.
There we go.
Nice.
Is the game low?
The game sound?
Or are you just wanting the BGM?
The music up.
Is the sound okay?
It's good?
Okay, okay.
Just making sure.
Oh, why do I keep doing that?
I know what you are.
Wait, what is this?
What is...
What do we need you for?
Oh, I thought I was gonna have to destroy it.
Okay.
You don't think it'll fall off the platform, no?
Free blade!
I
guess we'll...
We won't know.
It made it!
Oh my gosh.
Yeah!
I'm too good!
Yippee!
Oh, oh, I can't move.
Okay.
That was so rude.
Wait.
How did I...
What's happening?
Where did...
When did I...
Who did I...
How did I...
Oh.
Come here.
Come here, you.
Oh.
You stupid little...
Whatever you are.
Yeah!
Got his butt.
Easy.
I'm grabbing you.
Oh, dang it.
I tried to...
Oh.
I killed him already.
Oh!
One
second.
What did you say?
Yesterday was my birthday, but I didn't want to disturb the collab.
I'm sorry I missed people's birthdays yesterday.
Can I please get a happy birthday for my Kamiyoshi?
Of course, FredFrog.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear FredFrog.
The collab was fun.
It was...
It was very fun for me too.
Especially learning the game and stuff.
Seeing why it's the hot stuff.
For those who don't know, I played...
I played Repo.
Okay, I guess none of this stuff breaks.
I played Repo for the first time yesterday.
The R-E-P-O.
Wing Talisman!
A talisman made of crystallized angel wing.
It can stimulate a divine response in specific equipment.
That was the mission, though.
Oh,
I could go in here.
What about in here?
Let me in!
Funny platform time.
I'm scared.
Okay.
Okay, where's the next part?
Oh, wait, I see it.
Oh, never mind.
Turn around.
Maybe I go over here.
Oh, something's glowing.
Something's afoot.
Roarbs are afoot!
It pays to be curious.
Imagine if there's fall damage in this room.
What is that thing?
More roarbs!
Okay, I'm gonna need you to grab that thing.
No!
Grab it, please!
Where are you looking?
Nero, please!
Oh!
Oh, gosh!
Am I missing something, or...?
Oh, there's another platform over there!
I see it now.
I was trying to grab for non-existent...
thing.
Oh, oops.
I messed up.
Okay, we're doing this on purpose.
There we go.
Okay.
Again!
It's actually kind of fun, though.
Striking it rich, baby.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, what's on this side?
A whole lot of nothing.
More nothing.
Oh, I have to...
Oh!
I did get it!
I got the holy water!
Oh, I didn't even realize that's what that was!
So the thing I was trying to grab earlier was the holy water?
I knew it with my sense.
Wait, so then...
What was I trying to grab?
That right there, that blue.
Actually, I don't know anything anymore.
Wait, there's yellow here!
Oh!
Give me the star!
The vital star, please.
How do I grab it?
Oh!
With my hand.
Wait.
Nero.
He's reaching for everywhere, but...
He's reaching for every...
Ah, I got it.
Okay.
You forgore?
I did for a brief moment, and then I remember.
And then I remember.
Nice!
I remember.
I rem...
Ah, shoot.
I tried to do it.
Oh, we're in this room again!
Oh,
these guys too?
Oh my gosh.
Yeah!
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Do I have to lock on for that?
Or am I just doing it wrong, I think.
Oop!
You're still a little clown.
Oh, I'm still a little clown.
Oh!
What am I...
What am I attacking?
Oh my god, there's so many of them!
Ouch!
Please!
There we go.
God, it's a little stinking, but...
I lost my...
I lost my style points!
Ouch!
I tried to avoid it.
Those chickens don't look very appetizing.
They're so skinny!
This is the way I need to go.
This is the way...
I came from.
Yeah, the floor fell through.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
This is the way I need to go.
Skinny chicken.
Who's here?
Oh, we're in the hallway!
Oh!
Oh, why?
I could do it before.
Wait.
Ah, I did it!
I did it!
He just wasn't in the air.
But I got a little bit of a move in.
Oh.
Where are you?
Come here.
Oh, he was still dying!
Atomic.
Spin to win.
Wait.
Maybe I'm not getting enough air.
I think it's...
It's definitely my fault.
I'm like, trying to spin.
These ice guys were in the first game.
Were they?
What?
Where...
Where do I...
What do...
I got the thingy that I needed.
What to do with the thingy that I got.
Slight pause.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm just...
I'm just whacking it off.
Away.
Wait, I'm whacking...
I'm whacking...
I'm whacking too much.
I'm whacking it too much.
I'm whack...
I'm whacking away in the air way too much.
You guys know what I'm saying.
I'm just whacking it...
Whacking away.
I'm like...
Where do I go?
Wait.
The mission.
Oh, I didn't mean to taunt.
I'm just taunting to nobody.
Weed whacker.
We can now get a blorb.
Another blorb, I think.
Which is great.
Main hall?
Where is that?
Oh, where am I?
Where do I go?
Main hall.
The middle is...
The red door next to you.
Thank you.
That's right!
The wing talisman is vibrating.
It must be reacting to something in this room!
And we get to bounce again.
Hold on, let me get my money first.
Sorry, guys.
I'm obsessed.
Where is my money?
The church owes me a lot of money.
Can you imagine being the priest who, like, keeps putting these chairs out?
Like, someone keeps destroying all of our...
All of our seats!
And then he comes back 20 minutes later.
And they're all...
They're all destroyed again.
We need to get this done before Sunday, or...
Or our audience won't have anywhere to rest.
Okay, where am I going?
Here.
Oh, actually...
Oh!
Oh, I didn't think that would work.
Right in between the eyes.
Okay, so I'm guessing when I go through there, the...
I can't get...
Can't grab it midair, or...
I can grab it midair!
I learned.
But my thing is also reacting.
Oh, what could it be reacting to?
Oh!
You need air hike to get up there.
I think so, too.
Ah,
I don't have enough style points.
I could, like, if I could buy it with rorbs, you know, I'd buy it with rorbs, but...
We also just...
It sucks you don't get the style points until the end of the...
Until the end, you know.
Even still, I don't even know if I'd have enough.
You're such a genie.
Refund everything and get air hike.
Oh, yeah, I think maybe actually we can do that, and then we'll just get it, right?
We'll get it back.
Okay, so cancel all is refund.
Okay, abilities.
Air hike.
Confirm.
Yes, all right.
Also, um, item.
Let's grab a blorb while we're here.
Very nice.
Okay, so...
Watch it be a secret level.
That's just like...
You're gonna...
Oh.
You're gonna really want every skill besides...
Wait.
Guys, what am I doing wrong?
Nero, use your arms!
Reach up, Nero!
Need level three.
Exceed.
Oh.
Let's exceed.
That one.
Oh, exceed three?
Increasing the x gauge to three slots allows you to...
Exceed is the rev bar.
Extends attacks.
Well, I'm gonna just gonna...
Well, I'm gonna cancel all.
I'm gonna get our stuff back because I don't know if we're about to go into a fight or if this is the end of the mission.
So, what did I have?
I had this one for sure.
We had this one for sure.
Oh, I didn't do exceed yet.
We did streak.
I don't think I have caliber.
Snatch two.
There was something else we had.
Oh, speed.
Okay, that's all that we had.
Okay.
We'll come back for it.
Some people are saying you can come back for it.
No money.
Grab.
Can I grab that?
Grab that.
Depth perception doko.
I don't even know where it is.
It's behind...
Oh, I thought it was behind the pillar.
Wait.
Oh.
Nero?
Oh, there we go.
Every time I start to start to question him, he actually does his job.
Wow, this is so long.
I don't want to get shocked.
Electrocuted.
Just grab it.
As long as you don't call him Dante.
He's still alive.
Oh, I think there's something wrong with our guy.
Nah, this is how he always wakes up, probably.
Do you guys not wake up like this?
That's what happens when you embrace the power of God and anime.
No way, he thought that was normal and fine?
Wait.
It is only a matter of time before his location is revealed.
True.
Oh my gosh.
This guy reminds me of the crazy scientist dude from Final Fantasy 7.
Luke.
Hojo?
Is that his name?
Cocky Kid Nero?
Yes!
Our priority is to capture Dante.
Why you...
I don't think we can keep calling him the holiness.
Nice stutter, nerd.
Hey, I haven't stuttered too.
Hey, I haven't stuttered.
All right, I forgot.
C!
I wish we got 5,000 points that I could use.
See, we don't even have enough.
I didn't think so.
Dang it.
Oh my gosh, how did I not get all the rorbs?
Crazy.
Dab.
Next.
Mission.
Resurrection.
Release the true power that resides within.
Okay.
I think I, yeah, I spent everything on the blorb.
We have a couple vital stars.
I got four of them.
No M stars.
Only S stars.
Definitely no L stars.
Only W stars.
Mission Chuni time.
Are we gonna get devil mode?
Devil trigger mode?
Coldy water one.
Blorb.
We can only get one more blorb, you guys.
This is so sad.
This is so, so sad.
And yeah, we're gonna, I guess, save up for air hike still.
Should be, hopefully, the next mission, right?
Hopefully.
All right.
Every blorb is precious.
But what if we find a blorb in the wild?
Like, like so.
We can still add more blorb if we find them in the wild, no?
Blorb spotted!
I like how it's literally just out in the open.
You just have to be paying attention.
Oh yeah, for those asking, the blorbs give you more to your health, more to your HP bar.
I'm just going down.
Make my tummy drop a little.
Oh, this is the...
By your hand, you cannot break our clasp.
The power lies in another's grasp.
Okay, I got that.
Which way should we go?
Oh, I think that's...
Wait, is this a door?
Okay, I guess I only have this way.
Good job.
Nice try, Nero.
Raiden!
These are so cool!
Yeah, yeah, he's reminding me.
Oh shoot.
Oh, they attack when they're red.
Oh, they're like the things before.
Oh, I should grab them, maybe.
Let's see.
Oh gosh.
That's so unfair.
Don't attack all at once, please.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Oh.
Nice.
It's so dramatic.
Where are they?
Nice.
Where did he go?
Where'd he go?
Grab him!
There we go.
There we go, okay.
Those guys, they're like...
Yeah, they're like the chest pieces that would attack when they were red and not when they're blue.
Meow.
They look like eyeballs.
I have you.
Little loopy loop.
Anymore?
Can you guys hear the church bells?
Eyeballs.
Puzzle time!
Oh!
Who dat?
Uh-oh, I'm playing a board game with myself.
Concerning life and death in this hell, we are the ones who weave that spell.
I hope
you're lucky.
I'm not.
Oh, if moving forward is what you intend, then guiding your other self to the door is what we recommend.
I also recommend learning meter.
And now your fate, we decide.
Strike us or your progress will be denied.
They're trying, they're trying.
Game room.
Man, am I handsome.
So I'm guessing...
Okay, so we have to land on this.
It seems to be.
I'm guessing if we land on like red, then enemies will come.
If we...
We'll see.
I guess we'll see.
Five!
One, two, three, four.
I guess we'll figure it out now!
What's happening?
Oh my god.
A void?
Uh,
lasers!
Uh, there's no purple.
Okay, just kidding.
Easy.
Okay.
You who grasps the die with devilish hand, your fate is sealed by the die's command.
No matter what fortune you hope to receive, with your devilish touch, unknown fate the die will weave.
Red equals cardio, yeah.
Six.
Five!
White.
We're safe, we're safe, we're safe, we're safe.
Six!
Nice.
Oh, man.
Again?
You can't catch me.
They're eating my dust.
Timer sometimes increases.
Two!
Oh, come on.
Ouchy, ouchy.
Come here, come here.
Ouchy, ouch.
I like stripping it naked.
I like taking its clothes.
Grab, grab, grab.
You're naked.
Grab your tops, grabs your bottoms, grabs your panties.
Three!
Fortune!
Oh.
Did it just send me back?
What?
You asshole!
Four.
DMC like Akiba's girl.
Fortune real!
Oh my god!
It's raining men.
It's raining roars.
So if I get a two, I don't want that.
Oh, five.
Please be lasers.
Dang it.
I love throwing it into the other guys.
It's so much fun.
Okay, where's our other guy?
I don't know the other words.
Do you need to know them though?
What a crazy taunt!
He's just like, I'll slit your throat.
Oh.
Ah,
dang it.
I tried to do it.
I did the move, but I was already...
Okay.
You should see the S-rank taunt.
Three.
One, two.
Oh, we're safe.
Okay, as long as I can get...
Where are we at?
I don't have to get exactly, do I?
Is it gonna be like bouncing me back and forth?
If I get like a four, is it gonna go one, two, three, four?
Or do I have to get exactly a three?
The time has come and so have I.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Three or more?
Okay, okay, okay.
All right.
Lady luck.
Oh my god.
Wow.
That's my favorite part of that song.
The, uh...
Oh, it was a time guy.
Of the Umapyoi Densetsu.
That's my favorite line of the song.
It's talking about, it's like...
Hey, lady luck, kiss me today.
Strange room.
The ambiance goes crazy.
Oh, those look ominous.
They definitely won't come alive.
Minta, that's me.
There's a secret afoot.
Wimpy sword.
Oh, this guy.
Hojo.
Yeah, this is how the song goes.
The time has come and so have I.
Agnes.
Stake.
Pipi.
Dang,
it's brief.
Your d-d-d-d-demise.
Don't you think that's a little harsh?
Killing me because the way I t-t-t-t-talk.
Oh, he's so...
Hero!
Buster always makes it land on the next round of rotation.
Oh, I didn't realize.
Thanks, Lori.
Thank you for the pink super chat, by the way.
I appreciate it so much.
Thank you.
More demons.
This...
This is all Kratos doing.
Kratos.
Yeah.
Oh.
D-d-d-d-d-duel!
Oh, dead.
Oh, these are the sword thingies.
Grab it.
Oh shoot.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh gosh, they hurt a lot.
They hurt a lot.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Dang it.
Oh my
god.
Oh, what's happening?
Understood?
Understandable?
Please, let me grab him.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
That
was close.
Oh, oh gosh.
Run, run, run, run.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, I don't have double.
I don't have airhike.
Health,
health, health, health, health, health.
Run, run, run, run, run.
Ouch.
Wait, how do I avoid this?
Oh, I think I should attack like while I'm in the air probably.
Ouch.
You jerk.
Okay, okay.
I might have to do this one again.
That's okay though.
Oh no, it still killed me.
Oh, that sucks so bad.
Or it still hurt me.
Yeah.
Run, run, run.
Okay.
Oh no,
please.
I'm gonna die.
The middle part is safe from the shock?
It is?
Oh, I was wondering that.
Okay, okay.
All right.
Run, I'll run, don't leave.
I mean, gyro.
I'm so sorry.
I have...
Oh shoot.
Ouchie.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
I didn't notice the...
Oh gosh, there's so many of them.
Oh, they're all coming after me.
Ouch.
What?
Yeah!
It took me a second to figure it out, but I got it.
Thanks for telling me about the middle.
That helped a lot.
It has only been a few years since I began this research.
He looks like Shigure Ui.
Which is all hunched over.
Have you guys seen those memes?
They're cracking me up.
It's the wish of His Holiness.
What a crock.
And you may as well ditch the efforts, pal.
Because His Holiness is dead.
Ah, but His Holiness has been reborn.
Reborn?
As an angel.
Me?
I don't know, that did not look very angelic.
Oh no, he's doing the thing that I do to them.
Oh, never mind.
See, but just a small fraction of my research...
Miro!
Dante's gonna come save us, probably.
Look, how beautiful this white armor stands.
You have no idea the hardship to make just one armor come to life.
Then why are there so many?
I had to capture and control countless demons to harness their souls.
Summoning them alone was almost an insurmountable task.
They do look really nice, though.
Summoning?
So was you, who made the gate.
Yes, yes, the Hell Gate.
I created it merely as a reference and substitution for the real gate.
But after utilizing an extremely powerful devil's arm...
Yeah, they look really awesome.
Kind of chunky.
I like it chunky.
It proves sufficient.
What the hell are you talking about?
I like them big.
I like them chunky.
You should rest.
Soon, you shall be my next subject of experimentation.
So that I can learn a little something from you.
French toast, yummy.
And that armor.
I feel like I have to whisper because they're so quiet in this game.
Never.
Oh, yes.
Take him out.
I thought he was like...
On a date.
No way.
Oh my god, wait.
Was I right?
We're harnessing...
Wait,
what did I just miss?
It's true form.
Oh my god.
Jojo.
Wait, isn't Jiro...
He's been a moth this whole time.
Matarikon.
Wait, he doesn't get a demon form, but he has a demon stand?
That's insane.
I
didn't know DMC4 was a love story.
They gave him boobs.
Bye, Jojo.
Agnus beef.
Agnus.
You must have known something.
Yamato.
Oh, that's why some of you guys were saying Yamato.
A sword imbued with tremendous power.
It unleashes the latent power within Nero.
Devil...
Sorry, I swallowed my spit wrong.
lol Press LB to release the demonic energy within Yamato and unleash the devil in Nero.
Uh-oh.
Now we have to start buying plorbs.
We have wasted all...
Well, I guess we didn't waste the money, but we spent all our money on plorbs.
Within your deity gauge to transform and using this energy will deplete your gauge.
Our thing is going crazy.
Our arm, I mean.
Can I destroy all this stuff for money?
No?
We plorbing now.
Yeah, we got plorb.
Oh!
Destroy the research!
Destroy for plorb!
No?
Okay.
I love that.
Thank you.
More...
puzzle time.
Yep, yep.
Is this the puzzle?
Yeah, we're like a quote puzzle.
Oh!
Whoa!
We activated the dam.
Visuals in this game are great.
Why did I do it one at a time?
Okay.
Oh.
No, no.
Right...
There!
Is it too short?
No.
Is my arm too short for it?
Maybe...
This one's hard, you need to jump.
Okay.
Thank you.
I can't tell when I can't...
My depth perception tends...
It's once again becoming the final boss.
I know I keep falling.
I'm trying to jump.
Why do I keep falling?
Oh, don't jump off the side of the...
Don't jump off the side, Nero.
I guess I need to time it.
He's a clumsy guy.
Try doing stinger.
Oh, like...
Oh, okay.
Okay, there we go.
The camera.
Ah, I didn't lock on.
But that got me pretty...
I know the camera change really does get me.
Okay, that was...
This was good though.
Just kidding.
Hello?
Oh, I'm pressing that.
That's why I'm stupid.
We need the blorb.
Yeah, we get good distance with it.
Sorry, I'm gonna be really stubborn about this, guys.
This is my new...
Metal Gear Ration.
You gotta let it out.
Pull your devil trigger to embrace the darkness within you and move fast, baby.
Don't be slow.
Thank you.
Jump towards it with streak.
Wait, that's what I'm doing, right?
I'm using streak.
I'm been using...
I'm doing streak.
Oh, just try streaking instead.
Oh.
Ah!
Oh!
Oh, it's that far.
Wow.
Did I miss a birthday?
Let her cook.
Today's my birthday.
Can I get a happy birthday song?
Of course, Kodamushi!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Kodamushi.
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday.
Fellow Minto.
Mint-mine!
Thank you for 10 bucks.
All right, all right, all right.
All right.
Oh.
That didn't...
That wasn't effective at all.
We're locked in.
No.
No, I need you to go forward.
No!
Not that way.
I meant your other forward.
I wish I had air hike right now.
I wish I had air hike.
This is putting down our...
What's it called, you guys?
It's putting down our time.
I'm gonna get a lower score.
Don't press grab.
I'm not, I'm not, I'm not.
I'm just, I'm just streaking.
I'm just streaking.
I think I gotta...
Okay, I gotta angle it though.
Oh my gosh!
Why'd you go that way?
Go to the right, please.
I'm gonna start from over here.
I wish I could change the camera, you know.
Okay, maybe like that.
Why?
Stop going that way.
Stop going that way, please!
One charge of rev intense.
I don't think it's, I don't think it's...
I think it's more so the...
The angle.
No?
It's the angle rather than the distance, I think.
See, like, this looks like it would be fine, no?
But it keeps going.
Okay, let's get the heck out of here.
Yeah, see, oh, thank you whoever suggested streak instead of the grabby grab.
That was way easier.
Nice.
All right.
Whoa, that's a big wall.
Who is it?
Oh, it's just you.
Oucha, oucha.
I'm glad the wall doesn't attack us anymore.
Oh, oh, oucha.
You have no sword to depend upon.
Oh, oucha.
Oh, DT's.
Now we gotta try it.
Another thing for me to remember.
It's literally the game.
What's that thing?
Looks so cool.
Um...
Oh, there's people in there.
Oh, there's a secret here.
This is...
Aiming into so you know grabs and DT are much stronger and you can spam gun during DT grabs.
You can spam gun and grab.
Tracking treasure down.
Find all the hidden...
This is speaking my language.
Wait, we're going on a treasure hunt.
A 99 of them.
Wait, maybe I'm bad at this.
Wait...
That's the door?
That was the door.
So silly.
That was so silly.
GG speedrun.
I'm guessing this is above?
Okay, hold on.
My all-time favorite food.
Wait.
Hold on.
And I gotta concentrate.
I don't really have an all-time favorite food.
Wait.
Stop moving?
Oh.
Is that what I'm doing wrong?
Hold on, let me go back to this first one.
When does it become the brightest it can be?
Like this looks so bright.
Maybe it's up above.
Whack it.
This thing?
Wait, whack what?
Oh, this thing.
Oh, you guys are so...
You guys are so smart.
Okay, so there was three...
So there was probably just one more that we needed to get.
Okay, we can do this.
We can do this.
Thanks for the help.
That was sneaky, huh?
Okay, so there's this one first.
They're like, you're gonna leave?
Nah, JK.
There's this one.
Oh, there's not this one.
Oh, is it random each time?
Uh-oh.
I think it's random.
Okay, not here.
There was something over here.
Maybe like here?
No.
Here?
Do I go up even more?
Time to panic.
My strategy!
My stride is completely lost.
And so am I.
Okay, let's go to the bounce.
Unless it's down here.
No, it's definitely not.
There only is this level.
Okay, we're gonna have to do it again.
Attack the mirror.
You think that's it?
Okay, we got that one.
Okay.
Wait, but there was something glowing on the other side.
I wonder if you could duel the other one, maybe.
Surely it being random means it can be brute force, no?
No thinking required.
Wow, we only have four seconds left!
Craziness.
Where'd the blorb spawn at?
Oh, over here.
Yippee!
Yay!
Wait, there's more here.
Unless it's still reacting to this.
I think it's still reacting to that.
Nice!
Okay.
Yummy blorb.
I think we just need...
Let's see.
Yeah, we just need one more for another blorb piece.
I need health desperately.
I need health bad.
Reminder about DT.
Thank you, I'm gonna do it!
Now.
Oh, okay.
I suck.
Oh my gosh, it's so little.
Where'd he go?
So have I.
Woo!
The time has come, and so have I.
We're going this way, right?
Okay.
Again!
Buster is so cool.
Oh my god, there's so many of them.
Oh, there's so many of them!
I'm scared of dying!
Oh gosh, they're all revving.
They're all revving.
Ouch!
Oh!
Nice.
We got two for one.
Very good.
Oh, there we go.
Oh my gosh, where'd that guy come from?
I'm gonna die!
DT!
Okay, okay.
Oh, I can't DT yet.
Sucks, sucks, sucks, sucks.
Okay.
Good thrusting, thank you.
I didn't die, but I'm barely alive.
Oh, what's around here?
In here?
What is it?
Lots of robes, baby.
Nice.
This is the way.
Is there anything over here?
It doesn't seem to be.
Taunt restores DT.
Oh, we got a little bit of green.
Oh, eat your greens, everybody.
Could have been worse.
Hold on, let's check this.
Nice.
Please give me health!
Please!
I'm begging you!
I'm on my knees!
Please give me health!
I'm begging, I'm begging, I'm begging!
I'm on my knees!
Begging please for some health!
This is a tiny bit of green.
Please, just a tiny little bit.
No health.
Sad.
It's been nice knowing you guys.
This is where we found the...
Lord piece before.
I-I-R-C.
Please, please, please.
Just a little green.
I like how so many of these songs sound very similar.
But they're like different at the same time.
I got it though.
So we have a DT now.
My arm is still glow- Oh, it's glowing because of this.
That's right.
Um...
Was there something we couldn't do?
Because we didn't have a DT before?
We got that down.
Hold on one second.
My chat froze again.
Buy more porbs.
I can do that.
Oh, wait.
He's like, the guy's watching from the window as I destroy this.
He's just like a single tear coming down his face.
He's like, I just, I'm in, he's like, I'm in hell.
I just put those back.
He's like, today I'm gonna discover the scoundrels.
That keep stealing our chairs.
He keeps destroying them.
Not again.
It's literally- Hold on, I'm trying to fix my chat.
Sorry, guys.
It's literally one of those moments of the cabbage guy from Avatar.
Kids these days.
And then you see- It's just Nero's got a lot of aggression, you know?
He's just really gotta let it out.
Oh!
We cannot buy P.O.R.B.
yet.
How curious.
I guess starting the next- The next mission from forward?
Hold on.
Please refresh.
I'm begging you.
Sneaky blorb.
She can't see us.
I can!
Kind of.
I have to read you through OBS.
Guys, I am once again asking for a hint on where to go.
Shall we dance?
Shall- Oh!
It worked!
I worked!
Okay.
Second floor doors.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Does it matter which one?
What are we glowing about, huh?
Is it this?
Oh my gosh!
We got a blorb!
Full health, baby!
Oh my gosh!
Nice!
Oh, nice!
Wait, do you guys see that over there?
Does this one also?
Is there even a mirror over here?
Maybe not.
Oh, there is.
Now I'm just destroying- My arm's not even glowing.
I'm just destroying this to be a menace.
Oh, it's- There's nothing even behind it!
But do you guys see that thing?
Can I grab that?
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
I'm finding everything right now!
Nice!
Okay, now we'll go through the door.
Oh, that's not the door.
Now we'll go through the door.
Real.
Oh, we're in here!
Yeah!
Oh!
Slam dunk!
Oh, he had like one measly health left.
I'm not letting you do anything that you wanna do!
I hate chairs!
Oh, I forgot that I can use this thing too!
Anything else?
Alright.
I hope I'm going the right way.
Bullying them.
This is the wrong place?
Oh.
Ow.
Thank you.
Oh, shoot.
We'll just run.
Wrong way.
I'm almost positive those doors made a loop, no?
This one?
Door next to the painting.
Painting.
Door next to the portrait.
But there's two of them.
This one?
The loop doors.
Either work?
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna go this way.
I fear the game does not do a great job of telling you where to go.
Oh!
Come here!
Or maybe it does, and I'm just not paying attention.
Am I just not paying enough attention?
There is a map.
Yeah, but does the map tell you where to go?
Slam dunk, baby!
Waterfall.
Hold on.
I want to get a good styles.
There we go.
It's been a week since you saw it.
Oh, it has, yeah.
I have many game on the brain, too.
Many game on the brain.
I'll be honest, I don't know how many games I have on the brain.
Does this want me to DT and use it?
I don't want to waste it, though.
No?
Okay.
I've been playing a lot of Ground Zeroes.
That's been on my mind the most.
Oh, we made it!
Does that red thing do anything?
Oh, well, I should have checked it.
All right, oh.
Forward we go.
Forest entrance?
It was a fan.
I'm going into a forest?
Oh my gosh.
Whoa!
Whoa, I'm in the jungle!
Any minkies about?
This is the most green I've ever seen in these games, ever.
Oh my gosh, just would imagine Snake coming down doing his...
What the hell?
This looks just like it.
This is like where Snake finishes his Halo jump.
What the hell is this?
Sorry, kid.
This is gonna have to wait.
Where did he come from?
Where is he going?
What the hell is this?
How much could he really know?
More than you, little baby.
Oh my goodness.
Thank you.
Oh wait, we got a ton of points this time.
We got a lot of points this time.
Let's go!
Cab.
Turn it up, turn it.
Oops.
Why is that lady from before?
The plot.
A million memes of Dante looking at various things.
I believe it.
Booba booba.
Who's the other cloaked creature?
Who is that guy?
She's got...
Wow!
She's got boobs.
Ooh, they're talking about you.
Ooh, maybe it should have like...
Maybe it should have waited a little longer.
No,
they're gossiping.
They didn't even give her time to leave the room before they gossiped.
Yeah, what is he investigating, huh?
That menace, Nero, appears to be quite close to Kratos' sister, Kyrie.
More than once, he called out her name.
They're gonna use the girl.
They're gonna use the girl mission.
The She-Viper.
Proceed through the Forest of Ruin.
Evil Pope smile.
I mean, don't believe she's here.
Ah, Edith P!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Viper?
Snake?
I've been called a viper once.
All right.
Oh, no!
Wait a second.
I might be able to get the trigger heart, though.
Hold on, let's see if we can get both.
Abilities?
Air hike?
I can't.
I thought I had...
I thought it cost less than it did.
Still waiting for mine.
It might be...
It might depend on which batch you got it...
your plushie from.
Because there was...
They did have to do a second batch.
And those will be shipped around July.
If I remember correctly.
So...
Apologies if you have to wait a little longer.
I'm sorry.
Maximum bet and show...
Oh.
Maximum bet.
When the devil trigger is active while on the ground, press R, B, back, Y, B.
Yamato and the Red Queen combine to take on all foes.
Charging the attack will increase its power.
So...
You lock on.
Then you press Y and B.
And then show down.
When devil trigger is active while on the ground, press R, B, forward.
Oh, so it's the same, but forward and backward.
Nero himself unleashes Yamato with an omnipotent barrage of slashes.
Whoa, that looks insane.
Oh my goodness.
We'll have to save up.
I do want the trigger heart mostest.
But right now, we will...
We'll stick with double jump.
We'll stick with air hike.
We might be able to get enough in the next thing.
We'll see.
Oh, wait.
I don't think I can get anything else.
Oh, there's the porb!
We can get porb.
We're porbin', we're porbin', we're porbin', we're porbin'.
What?
It's good.
Nice.
Nice, nice.
Oh, and then we can...
Oh, I was like...
I was like, wow, it feels like they added a ton more stuff.
Yeah, because they added the double stars.
Yes.
Yeah, DT is useful now.
I know, right?
We can actually use it now.
Nice.
All right.
Wow,
what a peaceful forest.
Ooh!
Ew!
What are these?
Let me turn it down a little bit, sorry.
I keep turning it up during the cutscenes.
This looks ominous, no?
If I stop moving...
Not the jungle music.
Whoa!
Oh my gosh, you sent that donut at the same time that it exploded.
And so I thought it was...
I heard, like...
I heard just barely within the screams, like...
Nero hitting chairs is such a good joke that I'm still laughing.
It will make sense in DMC5.
Mint Jimbo does it again.
Really?
I should be a game dev.
I would create the most cursed thing ever.
Okay.
Onwards through the jungle.
In the jungle, the mighty jungle.
The Nero sleeps tonight.
Oh, in the jungle.
Oh.
Oh, he's so tiny down there.
What is that thing?
He's just creepy crawling.
Oh, there's a couple of them.
Creepy crawlers.
Hold on, guys.
I gotta get my stuff first.
Little ants down there.
Oh, I'm watching from up here.
I'm so chill right now.
I need my skin.
Hold on, I saw some little eggies on the wall.
If I go this way...
Oh, here one.
How do I get that guy?
No, like...
No.
Maybe...
There we go.
Eww!
Bug, bug, bug, bug, bug, bug.
Bug, bug, bug.
Bug.
Bug!
Oh, I squished him.
Oh, I squished him again.
Nasty.
I like how I'm losing...
I'm like technically losing points as I'm vibing to the music.
But it's just hard not to just, you know...
Take it all in for a little bit, you know?
The time is coming, so have I.
Let's try in here.
Ah,
these guys.
These clowns again.
Literal clowns.
Oh, friendly fire.
Oh, is he possessing it?
Oh my gosh!
Last of us.
Easy mode.
Nastyness.
That was so gross.
There's a whole egg.
Egg area.
Wait.
Let me in!
Look at all those eggs!
I gotta crack them.
What the heck are these supposed to be?
Ducks?
Hit it harder?
Yeah!
Oh!
You're right!
You're so right!
Hey!
Just like the gla- the mirrors.
Look at the middle one too.
I hate property!
Insurance companies hate him.
Actually, would they hate him or would they love him?
They're always having to do payouts because of- because of him.
Right?
They would hate him.
That's a little icky.
Can I jump over it?
No.
Aha!
Ah!
Sad door.
How much do you like jumping puzzles in DMC?
The most amount.
The most amount that you can love a jumping puzzle, no?
Oh boy.
This isn't so bad though.
These are fine.
Does it get worse?
You'll love the next part.
Oh geez.
Oh.
Oh no!
Wait!
Ah, ouch!
Do I have to kill them to progress?
Oh.
That was so close.
Please!
Give me the next part!
Please just- Ah, no, no, no!
I need to kill these guys, like actually.
Oh my god, no, please.
No!
Yeah, get lost please.
I'm just gonna kill him like this.
Oh, no, no, no!
Where are my ghosts?
A ghost!
Oh.
Charged shot is really good against the ghosts, is it?
Ah!
I think I did pretty all right maneuvering around- Oh, dang it, I did not mean to do that.
I did all right maneuvering around them until I couldn't anymore though.
Okay, all right.
You can shoot- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, thank you.
Well, grabbing indeed.
I'm just gonna shoot them anyway.
Ouch!
They suck so much.
Oh, you know what?
Ouch!
Am I not supposed to be in DT right now?
Oh,
I hate these guys so much.
Please, no more of you.
Please, no more!
Please, I'm so done with you!
Please!
I don't want to deal with you anymore, but I can't leave until I finish defeating you guys.
Oh yeah.
I
think the other guy is lower on health, but it's okay.
Maybe I can get him like this.
Yeah.
It's a pretty lame way to die, but whatever.
Okay.
TMC2 skills live on.
There's a cheese way?
What is that?
What's that cheese?
What's the cheese?
There's a blorb on the platform.
Is it that thing up there?
Is that the blorb?
I thought that was one of the grabby grabs.
I have a question for this part.
If I kill them both, do they respawn?
So is it just kind of like outliving?
Or is it...
If I kill them, they're gone.
That's a blorb up there.
I gotta get it.
So they don't respawn.
Okay, they stay dead.
Okay, okay, okay.
They're just hard to kill.
They are!
They are very difficult.
Especially when you're stressing out over...
over...
over making it to the next platform.
Start the platforms and don't move!
Really?
No, these will definitely go away, no?
Oh.
Jump on and jump back?
Oh really?
Uh, I missed my chance.
Now I'll get to see what it does though.
And it goes around in a...
What is it?
Where does it go?
I'm observing.
Get on the spawn first.
My bad.
Wait, but when I restart it, will they not then respawn or no?
Blorb!
That's our chance to get the blorb.
They don't?
Oh, interesting.
Okay.
IDK.
Only one way to find out.
Yeah, I guess so.
Okay, then it becomes a long pathway over there.
The blorb is taunting me.
Alrighty.
Come here!
Only one appeared.
Hmm.
Where did the second one go?
That didn't go out far enough?
Uh-oh.
Well, I guess we'll see what happens.
Oh, I have to wait the whole way.
I'm sorry guys.
Okay, I gotta get on the second platform.
Okay, sorry guys.
Sorry for the wait.
Um, bathroom break?
I don't know.
Bathroom break time.
I have people messaging me.
What are they saying?
What's going on?
Mogu was like, I can't believe I experienced my first doomed yaoi with Irving and Bert in Severance.
Was MGS4 not doomed enough for you?
Oh, it's over.
Okay, good.
Was that not doomed enough for you?
Ah, second platform.
Yippee!
Oh, oh my gosh.
That was so close.
Holy moly.
Holy moly, that was so close.
Oh god, I got too excited.
Yeah, okay.
All right.
You can kind of see which ones are about to change because they turn blue.
So that's kind of nice.
They start...
Yeah, you see him?
You see him?
No.
Like that.
This is so easy.
Yippee!
This is so chill.
Lapis River.
Fancy.
That was just a nice little stroll.
No biggie.
NBD, NBD.
Oh, we got more of these.
Okay, I'll have to figure out a way to take care of those later.
Mini...
Camera change.
Roar.
What's here?
Oh, I see it, I see it, I see it.
What's this one?
Jungle parts are nice.
Secret mission.
Reach the goal by rising to the top.
Don't do this mission, it's hard.
Good luck with the secret.
I kind of want to see it, but if it's hard, let's try it.
Wait, this is a safe one.
Wait.
I'm getting mixed messages.
Oh,
uh...
I'm not gonna make it.
Do I go like here?
This one seems doable, I'm not gonna lie.
Wait, aim for under the fence.
Go under the fence.
Really?
This one seems doable, maybe.
As long as they're not about pure skill, I feel a little bit more confident.
Under the fence.
I'm on the fence, everybody.
Oh, oops.
I wish the camera angles didn't mess me up.
I don't think I can go under the fence.
Ah!
Oh, I was so close!
You guys saw that, right?
I'm not gonna make it.
I can't see!
No!
The grabby grabs are so inconsistent.
So close.
That was the last jump?
No way.
Okay, we can try it one more time.
Do you mind doing it again?
I will.
Oh my gosh, Lord Krosus, I didn't even recognize you.
I didn't even recognize you.
Change your profile picture.
Why do you guys do that?
Why do you guys change your profile picture so I can't recognize you?
I love the camera in DMC.
Oh, that's everybody's favorite part, no?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, the camera really screwed me over there.
Please, why is it doing this?
Oh my god.
Why is it suddenly messing up camera angle?
Why is it suddenly like this?
I wish I could restart the mission from here, honestly.
So I don't have to go through everything again.
Why is it acting like this?
I don't understand.
I'm not changing anything.
Oh my gosh, it's...
Okay, here's what's happening.
I'm pressing right on my joy-con.
Not joy-con.
This is not a switch.
Oh my god, on my...
Oh, I can't.
My brain is frying.
Joy-con.
The analog stick, yes.
It's because I played on this switch before.
When I was playing the first...
The first three.
Please!
I can't tell where I'm at.
I hate this mission.
I don't want to do it anymore.
The camera angle is making me so mad.
I can't.
I don't want to do it anymore.
Oh yeah, the door.
Let's just leave.
The camera angle is making me so angry.
That's what was making it difficult.
Oh, I was gonna say, any rorbs down here?
I knew I would be right.
I think that's all our rorbs in this area.
A little bit of health, nice.
We'll take it.
Oh!
Big!
Nice.
Ew, what was gonna hatch out of that sucker, I wonder?
Well, I almost did it.
We take those.
We take the almosts.
Ancient Plaza.
White Orb.
A magic white stone of crystallized devil spirit.
Revives lost magic power.
Nice.
Is that basically a devil star?
Warb!
Oh no.
Oh no, it transformed!
More?
Did you get possessed?
No, you're fine.
No possession on you.
Oh, there's more?
Oh!
Oh, they're hatching!
Yeah!
Destroy them before they hatch!
Ew!
Spawn kill!
Oh.
Nice.
Turn him into an omelette.
Uh, you gotta crush a couple of eggs.
Wait, what's this one?
Uh, Raiden!
So I'll make an omelette.
You gotta...
You gotta squash the eggs.
What's this artist trying to say?
You can't keep getting upset.
Just...
About the eggs.
Am I doing it right?
But
what is it actually?
Oh, can't fret over every egg, uh, Raiden.
Woo!
We're gonna do this thing.
Oh,
so close.
Almost got the double hitter.
Wait, what did I just...
What did I just kill?
Oh, he's behind the...
He's behind the wall.
Uh-oh.
Wait, crap!
Grab and shoot.
Oh, grab, grab and shoot.
I'm not sh...
Oh.
Use the gyro...
Where is it?
Uh, I lost it.
I don't know where the gyro went.
Where did it go?
Mother of all eggs.
Oh, we're creating the mother of all eggs.
You can't fret over every omelette.
Yeah, I remember now.
Oh, oops.
Uh, oh, here?
I'm just gonna...
We're gonna get into the position.
Dore the explorer.
Can I beat these up?
Hold on, I wanna make sure.
I'm not missing any rorbs.
We gotta get as many points as we can, guys.
Okay, I think we're good.
It's the opposite way around.
Wait, no, I'm going the right way around.
Egg of all omelettes can't fret over every mother.
Yeah.
Like your attention to detail.
Thank you.
This is just like one of my Japanese animations.
I know I need to stop quoting Metal Gear when playing this game, but I also can't help it.
Oh.
Lost time?
Lizard.
Did we just get eaten?
Nope.
Miro's too good for that.
Oh my gosh.
I missed one.
The green.
No!
I made it.
Oh man, I missed one.
Forgotten ruins.
You can buster it.
Oh, that's right.
Thank you for the reminder.
Hey.
Hey, you.
You first.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We don't want you infecting anybody.
Yeah, you tried to come up on me.
You can't.
Oh man, I missed it.
Oh.
Oh, have we
got it?
Literally just a single R.O.R.B.
I lose my mind.
Oh.
There will be a day when we are just one R.O.R.B.
off of what we need.
I'm telling you.
It'll happen.
And then I'll be thinking...
Or we'll be one R.O.R.B.
over what we need.
And I'll be thinking...
Yeah, that one R.O.R.B.
in the river.
It was important.
I am a greedy streamer.
I am greedy, okay?
Let's see.
More P.O.R.B.
Nice.
Skill... Oh, we can't do any more skill up.
Are we just getting through the forest?
Is that what we're supposed to be doing?
Oh, Den of the She-Viper.
Uh-oh.
That don't sound good.
Boss time?
Um, boss lady?
I wish that...
I.P.'s weren't...
Such, like, an annoying thing.
It would be incredible to have...
Like, a video game theme park.
Like...
You know, Nintendo...
That's the one thing about...
That's nice about, like, Nintendo properties.
Is that, you know, they're...
Like, Mario's owned by Nintendo.
But, like, with this, it gets complicated.
Like, imagine having this as a ride.
Like, a roller coaster.
Oh!
What the heck?
Did she just throw her seed at me?
I think she wants me.
She looks like a strawberry.
I like that.
Gosh, sorry.
How do I...
How do I dodge her?
Oh, child!
How do I avoid the...
What the heck is this?
Oh, it's one of these things.
Ouch!
Oh my gosh!
She doesn't like that.
How do I avoid the attack?
Just by jumping?
Okay, that's what I'm doing.
But I'm still getting hit.
Oh!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, I'm definitely gonna have to...
Redo this fight.
That's okay, though.
Oh, gosh!
Oh.
Oh god, she's still having babies.
Wait.
Yeah!
Oh my god!
Insane!
Smoking style!
I am a saucy boy.
Oh, please, I'm trying to jump.
Hold on, I'm gonna use a item.
I'm gonna use an item.
Oh, why...
What just...
What just happened?
What just disconnected?
Hmm...
My controller's still working.
That's strange.
Okay, anyway.
Nice!
Ouch!
Hey, hey, hey!
My children!
Where are you, lady?
I'm stuck in the middle.
I'm stuck in the middle!
Please,
please!
There we go.
Holy moly!
A human!
Aw, dang it.
Nice!
We absorb her children.
Sephirothic fruit!
One of Echidna's seeds.
This fruit of her womb...
Oh, it really is her eggs!
Wow.
Holds the power that binds together demonic plants.
Those were the last of her eggs.
Hag.
Seems as though the Sephirothic fruit is in harmony with that strange tree.
Nice!
Maybe I didn't need the health, but it was good to do it just in case.
Probably.
We can recover here.
I figured there'd be...
There was health on the sides, but it's okay.
Why is this still not good?
Better safe than sorry.
Yeah, we did so well too!
So I wanted us to...
We were killing it.
Literally.
We were killing her.
You gamed.
We gamed!
Hello?
Oh, I just have to interact with...
Okay, nevermind.
Nice.
All right.
Yay!
We got less points than I imagined we would, to be honest.
With how many stylish points I got.
I wish we would get the stylish points in terms of the soul stuff.
95% of orbs found though.
It's kind of crazy.
Before we do...
Oh, because of the item!
You're right.
Embrace the light to escape the forest.
Okay.
Should we...
Save up for...
Oh wait!
Trigger heart!
Now we can get this one!
Now we can get trigger heart.
I was gonna say save up for these, but I think trigger heart will be really good too.
So that since...
It'd be better to use less double trigger.
Maze puzzle?
Uh-oh.
Anything else?
I'm thinking...
Why?
Oh, this is revving up.
Which I do sometimes when I remember.
I think I've used it once today.
Charge shot!
Uh...
No, that's...
Oh!
Snatch three, I really want.
I'm not gonna lie.
Rev up before fight.
Yeah, you're right.
You're right, you're right.
Why do you snatch so much?
Snatch is more likely to be useful too.
I think so too, right?
Charge shot three is Nero's biggest damage?
Really?
Do I need charge shot two and one?
Well, I need charge shot, right?
Or do I just need to get charge shot three?
Streak two?
Do I not have that one?
Oh, I don't.
Okay, so there's a couple.
I use streak a lot as well.
There's so many options.
So many choices.
You need to get one and two to get three.
Ah, okay.
You have to buy all of them.
Okay, okay, okay.
We could get streak two immediately because I use streak a lot.
Or I could wait for snatch three, which we might be able to get next round.
Either one will benefit me, to be honest.
Get streak two.
I almost feel like...
I almost feel like refunding this because I'm so bad at it.
Doing it.
I'm so bad at the roulette.
I'd never activate it like ever.
If you tap exceed after swinging, you gain it back.
Gain what back?
Oh, you thought I meant the game?
No!
You don't really use combo C either.
Oh, yeah, because it's like the yy pause.
I'm so bad at the combos.
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm not a fighting gamer gamer, so I never...
I don't think in combos, you know?
I'm never thinking that.
My brain does not work in that process.
I'm still beating things, though.
They're both great, but you can refund for something you'll use.
Maybe we can get it back later, you know?
Maybe if I refund...
Is there a way to refund?
Oh, yeah, here we go.
I'm gonna refund this.
And I'm gonna refund this for now.
We can get them back later because what I'll do is I'll get snatch three for now.
And then I could always get them back in the future.
Because those...
These...
These I use so much because I'm a one trick pony.
Let's do that for now.
The non-combo stuff is so strong, so it's fine.
This is such a pretty picture.
Take a screenshot.
Get some rollers.
Roaring time.
Where am I?
That's where you are going.
Wow.
Crush you!
Wait, that guy!
He's the important one.
There we go.
Okay.
Hey guys, I gotta get my rorbs.
Oh, yeah.
Anything else?
No, we're just running, running.
There were some...
Oh, I was gonna say there's some other tentacles we gotta get rid of.
EMC4 is autosave.
Yes, it's autosave.
So I'll...
I don't know who was asking.
But we're all good.
Or we should be good.
I think we're good.
Are we good?
Very good.
Is this not the area with the secret?
Oh, it's over on this side.
Nah, sorry.
No!
I'm gonna try one more time.
We have longer snatch now.
Jump, King.
Maybe the camera is fixed.
Yeah, maybe we just have to leave and come back.
And the camera will have fixed itself.
Oh, King.
Please!
I can't, I can't.
I'm pressing forward, please!
Oh.
That was my fault.
That one was actually my fault.
Redo.
The camera is so crazy.
The camera gets me the mostest.
Ah.
Because it changes my controls mid camera shift.
So I'm just like...
It's all about finding the rhythm.
Let go of lock-on.
I'm not holding it permanently, but I'll try to remember to...
Oh, I see.
Oh.
Oh,
maybe that's what was killing me before.
Whoever said that?
Actually, I think several people said that.
Wow, I did it so easily.
Oh my gosh.
I did it so easily as soon as I stopped locking on the whole time.
That's what was killing the camera.
Was me just locking on.
I didn't even realize.
Oh my gosh, I feel like such a fool right now.
I feel like...
Because it's me, I'm like...
I'm like, game, why are you messing up the camera for me?
It's me.
I'm my own worst enemy.
Wow.
I can't believe it.
Thanks, guys.
Foolish Minto.
Which way did I come from?
Oh, I came from over that side.
Yeah.
Because it says so on the map.
And then I need to go back to where we came from.
So it's this...
Am I...
Wait, am I going the right way?
I think I need the map map.
Oh, I wish it showed.
Oh, I guess we can technically go down...
Wait.
Yeah, we can go this way and then we go up.
And then these look to be...
These are most likely where those vines were.
I could go through this door, but wouldn't this one be easier?
Unlock the gray path.
What gray path?
Lower door.
This one, right?
The one in the middle of the screen.
The time is coming, so...
The game wants you to remember where the red vines were located.
Yeah, and I'm saying that they're most likely these two little areas, no?
Because they're the only ways I haven't gone yet.
So I feel like it's that area.
I'm gonna try going to this door down here.
Because the other one will be...
Oh!
Oh my god.
Hey, you!
Crush!
Oh no no no!
My roooorbs!
They're all over the ground!
All
my roooorbs!
Okay, and then I go up here.
Oh, up here.
Literally up.
Wait, can I go up there?
I can't go up there.
Oh, I could go around.
Because isn't this one the...
Isn't that the disappearing one with the flying guys?
This... this route right here?
That's why I avoided it.
In case you're wondering what my thought process is.
I like that it's starting to rain.
Keep going to the east.
Oh, we're back here!
Fun.
Oh, it's getting dark.
Wait.
Can I even go through this way?
It didn't let me before.
Oh, we can now!
We can now!
I'm spawn killing them.
Aha!
It wouldn't let us before, but now we can.
Okay, sorry.
I'm gonna go back to the map.
Ah, cute!
I remember this area.
I think.
Yeah!
Oh no!
Oh my gosh.
I can't get over there.
More?
Oh my gosh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
They were like, hey, you didn't let us possess any of them.
So we're just gonna spawn one in to make things...
not as... make things annoying for you, huh?
Oh, oops.
There we go.
Well now...
What?
Now I feel even more... I feel silly again.
Wait, what the heck?
Wait.
No, this is...
I feel silly again.
Okay.
Wait, keep going?
Am I?
We're going like the longest way possible.
Who knows?
Who knows if we could have even gone this way?
I don't know.
Well, this thing won't give me another boar, but...
Tomfoolery.
There's one guy right now in the chat punching the air being like, I tried to tell her.
You did not see my message.
No, please Gabe!
Gabe, would you be so kind?
Please!
Be...
Thank you for the gift.
Do you guys think ghosts are just...
No, I'm not even gonna read that.
Why would you say that?
Let me in!
Open the new war!
Oh, and they even put this platform here too because they're just pure evil.
They're pure evil.
I guess I could be roar farming right now.
I don't feel like it.
I'm angry.
Wait, why isn't it showing up anywhere?
Hold on, sorry about that.
Wait, how many gifted was it?
No, I thought it was just one.
How many gifted was it?
Why didn't it show up for me?
Hold on.
Oh, 50!
Oh my gosh, I'm so sorry!
Here I sound like I'm ungrateful.
It didn't show up as 50 for me.
Oh my gosh, thank you!
I feel so bad.
Thank you so much!
It usually shows up at the top, no?
All right, let's see.
Map.
Oops.
These are new guys, no?
What are these things?
Ouch!
Oh my gosh!
Are these the children when they grow up?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm just gonna keep whacking them.
Slam dunk!
Oh, they're strong.
Hahaha!
Oh, they're guarding!
There's the smart little guys.
It's so funny.
How many are there?
Shoo!
They look just like their mother.
Anymore?
That's it?
Oh!
Nero?
He's sneaking like a Looney Tunes villain.
I thought it would take me to the other side.
Okay, now we're in a bit of a predicament, no?
Uh...
What?
Oh, sorry, my chat froze.
I was like...
What's going on?
Uh...
You have one more door that you didn't try.
I do?
Take the leap of faith.
That's where I just was!
I was just there!
One more door that I didn't try.
Oh, this...
This one right here?
Uh, sorry, I'm gonna be looking at the map a lot.
Yeah, okay.
Oh, the big guy's not there anymore.
These little guys are!
Oh my gosh!
I would have known!
Oh, oh, uh-oh.
Ambush?
Oh,
there was a whole introduction for these guys and I just never saw it!
Hey, I spoiled the surprise!
Ouch!
Oh my gosh!
Ouchie, ouch!
Yeah, you tried to bite me!
I'll get your butt!
Yeah!
Oh, he's dead.
Yeah, I accidentally spoiled it!
That was so funny.
Oh no!
My raw arms!
I got him.
Invisible wall.
There for some reason.
Oh, no?
Huh?
Why wouldn't it let me go there?
Oh, that's so strange.
Oh, that works.
Okay, okay, okay.
We were in this area before.
I should have known that.
That was how that worked.
Miro can't get over one tiny measly little step.
This is just, just a baby.
It's just a baby!
God, this place is great for orb farming.
It always looks like a huge big money amount, right?
But you get like, measly little bits.
But it's exciting to see big orbs come out, you know what I mean?
What is his actual age in this game?
I don't know.
Okay, correct direction.
I know I don't need it, but it's...
What if, what if something starts spawning?
Or not, just kidding.
Okay.
It was through this door, no?
Yes.
So we went through this door.
Up here.
I remember.
I rember.
I rember, I rember, I rember.
Nice rember.
It seems like the set...
Oh, yes.
The strange tree.
Yes.
Oh,
I'm not hitting anything.
Stop blocking!
Why are the lizards so smart all of a sudden?
He follows me, it's so creepy.
Let's destroy all these before...
Before they all hatch.
The game would feel...
I feel like the game would totally do that to me.
Yeah, thank you.
Ouch!
What did you do?
Okay.
I got his ass when he tried to get me.
Hey!
DT'd just for one final hit.
Okay.
I'm still so curious what this is for.
All right.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
It was down here.
Finally, progress!
Oh,
you guys...
Wait.
Did we even make it to the maze?
Or is this the maze?
Have I been in the maze the whole time?
There's no way.
This is the maze.
I've been trapped for like 30 minutes.
Shit, I'm gonna die.
She's coming the wrong way!
This is a gentle forest.
Yet those who treat her unkindly will fall into darkness.
Those who do not wish for darkness should seek the light.
For if not, all efforts will be in vain.
Okay!
Holy...
Oh, god.
The maze was our mind.
I thought I was big braining it.
And yet, I just...
Can you guys just tell me where to go?
I've gone through so much trouble already.
I feel like just looking up a guide.
Does unkindness mean destroying the eggs or...?
Follow the sun is the hint.
Okay.
It's everywhere is the sun.
Everywhere is blinding.
Follow the light.
Opposite of shadows, so this way.
Okay.
Lost woods.
Wait, did I go the wrong way?
Opposite the shadow...
Oh, the statue's shadow.
Forgotten ruins.
Would have been fun if you got lost.
Sorry.
I'm tired.
Oh, don't jump down, Nero!
Whatever you do, don't do it.
Training ground.
I noticed there was a moth on the door.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I can't see.
Wait.
Silly.
That guy's down, at least.
There we go.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Have you tried smashing your furniture to see if any rorps come out?
I should.
I think that everybody should.
Smart idea.
Do not jump down.
Do not pass gold.
Do not collect $200.
I think I can get another porb.
I can!
Honestly, if I save up, I could get the last blorb.
Maybe I'll do that.
Maybe I'll get the last blorb and then we can focus on all on porb.
How many vital stars do I have?
Two?
That should be good.
For now.
Also, thank you for the help with the maze, you guys.
Usually, I would have just done it without a hint, like, from you guys.
But...
Since I wasted all that time running around, I just wanted to get it over with.
I'm sorry.
The intended way to get 100% red orbs is to jump off the balcony you were at and backtrack to the ledge you were on.
No!
Don't make me!
Please!
You're good.
Thank you for understanding.
I need to get more water soon.
Oh!
Caleb!
Uh...
What's his name?
Campbell?
Uh...
Kyle.
Korble.
What's his name?
Oh...
Credo!
lol
Yeah!
Who the hell is Dante?
Ha!
Hey, I'm like, basically your brother-in-law.
Credit.
So what is your holiness?
You're Pope Man.
Kirie.
Hurt me?
You don't.
You too.
No!
Oh, shoot.
I have been chosen to take the next step in evolution.
To become something far more than just a human.
I am an angel.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Oh, shoot.
Nice.
Nice parry.
Ouch,
ouch, ouch.
Nice.
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Ouch, ouch, I tried to dodge.
Uh...
Ah!
Please!
Ouch!
Oh my gosh.
I'm wasting my DT for this.
Please!
Oh my gosh, she's so good.
Okay, my bullets do nothing.
Oh, shoot.
Not this.
Come on.
Please!
I mean...
Ouch,
ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Shall we dance?
Oh no!
Oh my gosh, that was so close.
Wee!
Oh, no.
Ah, shoot.
I missed my charge.
Oh, no, I didn't.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Okay.
Why do I feel so slow on this?
This...
Oh, come on, please.
Ah!
Ouch, ouch, ouch!
Oh my god, he has so much health.
Oh...
Holy...
Oh my god.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
What the hell?
This is sad shit.
Oh my god.
Oh, he's too good at dodging.
Ah, guys, I can't dodge it well.
Oh, you asshole.
Why did you have to teleport away?
Right as I DT'd.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
That was scary.
Oh, he does it every time!
You bastard!
Oh, shit.
Yeah, you have your reason to retreat.
Yeah, yeah.
Me too.
That was so close.
Oh, Nero, please get out of the way.
Oh, damn it.
I didn't realize that was the move he was doing.
Oh, shoot.
I forgot.
Oh, I got him!
I got him!
I got his ass!
Oh, thank goodness.
Nice!
Wait, can I...
Okay, okay.
That was good.
Good damage.
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
Just in case.
I'm trying to parry.
Mother...
Damn it, I tried.
Oh, he's too good.
I think I'm gonna use another.
I only have one left.
My head is so sweaty.
Oh, he's going ham, he is.
Oh, the holy water.
Oh my gosh, I have three of them.
He's right here in front of me, right?
Let's check where he is first.
Okay, he's...
There we go.
Let's try it.
I can't believe that worked.
Splash them.
I need some water, bad.
Oh, he does.
Give it up.
I'm sorry, I forgot your name.
Credit card.
Yeah, I know, right?
I kind of wanted to use the holy water.
Because I was just like...
Isn't it so funny that like it used...
That it worked on a guy that said he's an angel.
Kitty, it's not what you think.
You still love me, right?
No, wait.
Kitty.
This isn't what you think.
I am Nero.
Why did you do this?
No, no.
No, no, kitty.
You could grab a spear?
That's crazy.
To protect you from the truth.
Nero is a demon.
Look at the sword this guy uses.
You think he's an angel?
Not to worry.
I have no intentions of harming her.
Wait, you're still gonna trust him?
Your attachment extends beyond friendship.
You're still gonna trust this guy who says he's gonna hurt you?
I can't let them do this.
Let her go!
Agnus!
How dare you use my sister?
This is my fight.
And I will finish it.
Let her go.
His holiness predicted your defeat.
And so ordered that your sister be utilized.
What?
Oh my god.
He's got his fake little halo.
It's literally his antenna.
Kitty!
Use Kitty, eh?
Where has he taken her?
Why is he so jacked?
Back to headquarters?
I'd assume so.
Nero, we must set aside this battle.
Until I find out the truth of this.
Yeah, you can't even stand up, dude.
We gotta stop fighting.
Not because I'm dying or anything.
But because I gotta, you know, I got stuff to do.
Shield once held by Credo.
Those who take it up will find a new source of power.
After completing a buster, continue to hold B.
By bringing a captured enemy close to you, you can use that enemy as a shield against attacks.
That's awesome.
Why do I feel so much faster now?
What the heck?
Felt like I was running through jelly before.
My ears.
Ah, we didn't get so many.
That's my fault.
I used like three items.
I'm sorry, everybody.
25 minutes.
Dab.
He was just that fast?
Is that really the case?
For you.
Locate the captive Kyrie.
I think, guys...
Hold on one second.
I didn't get through that many missions today, did I?
What did I end on before?
I ended on seven before.
Oh my gosh, did I only get through...
Wait, no, not seven.
What did I end?
How many missions did I get through?
Four.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say...
I ended on four.
Oh my gosh.
The missions feel so much longer this time.
Um, it's my...
Let me see if I want to do one more or not.
Let's do one more.
We got this one.
Let's do this one.
Oh!
I forgot to...
I forgot to buy stuff.
Oopsie.
I forgot to power up.
Yeah, we'll find a statue somewhere, probably.
Uh-oh.
What?
Friendly fire?
The demons are...
Oh?
Oh no.
What is this thing?
Oh gosh.
Uh-oh.
What are you?
Oh my god, he's right there!
He's right there!
Nero, watch out!
If I snatch him...
If I snatch him and hold it...
Uh, snatch and hold...
I want to use him as a shield.
Oh, whoops.
I'm so stupid.
I can't grab...
Are they too big?
Are they too big for me?
Woo-wee!
That's insane!
Oh my god!
That's so awesome!
Holy moly!
Wow!
Uh-oh.
We don't need...
We don't want these.
Wow, this place is so clean.
Ah, you should have been the one to fill your dark soul with the light!
Kind of vibes.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh!
Oh, oops.
Oh, whoops.
Ah, shit.
Just one more!
Come on!
Ah!
Try with the gun in the air.
Oh, wow!
We broke it!
I didn't break the other one before.
Interesting.
Also, these statues...
What is that?
A monkey?
What is this one?
Okay.
Uh, I think we only have the one door.
Just kidding.
We have this long hallway.
What's this thing?
Oh!
Ice monkey.
Wow!
Looks kind of demonic to me.
Oh!
The snake won't let it...
Looks like he was patting me on the back.
Oh, no!
Did that just activate...
Wait, did that just activate laser beams?
Oh, hate that.
Why did that...
Why did this happen?
I don't like that.
Oh, no!
My game just crashed!
No way!
Uh-oh.
Oh, my game just crashed!
I wonder if the game doesn't like me playing for so long.
And it's...
Hold on, it's tiny.
Let me make it bigger for you guys.
Eeeh!
I don't remember what I had it.
Maybe this.
Yeah.
Oh, just kidding.
Okay.
Back to the beginning of the mission.
Did it not autosave?
I guess we'll see.
Devil may crash.
Oh...
I
don't think we lost so much progress, I guess.
I'm gonna have to fight those guys at the beginning again.
Nah, just the one fight.
Stinky!
So stinky.
Maybe I'll get caliber.
Have a mid-air...
Or I just save up for this.
Caliber's hard to do, really?
This is just not streak, but in the end...
Its input is difficult.
Oh, really?
It's hard to remember?
So close to blorb.
We'll wait for blorb.
In the end, I'm not gonna do anything.
In the end, I'm not even gonna do anything.
Ah...
Frustrating.
Look at all this sweet money we almost missed out on, guys!
Blorb, blorb, blorb.
Can I skip?
Okay.
I'm just gonna skip the cutscenes.
Hope you guys don't mind.
They're protecting him!
That's so messed up.
It's kind of funny, though.
I like it.
Nice.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I...
I have to redo my style thing!
No!
That sucks, too.
Wait, I wanna do it again!
Come here.
Where'd you go?
No!
I wanna do the cool style!
Please!
Ah, we don't get to do it as cool because we're not in...
Man...
Combo practice.
I guess so, yeah.
Always kind of combo practice.
Though...
I am curious what this door leads to before if I...
Don't activate the lasers.
If there is anything behind it.
Oh!
I missed this over here!
A devil star!
Nice.
So we are kind of, you know...
Okay, it's right here.
So in the air, you said?
Like...
Shoot it in the...
If I...
Like that, or...
Oh, shoot.
Does all this work?
Oh, no!
There we go.
Smoking!
We're all revved up now.
So let's see if this door do...
Oh, it's just a wall.
I see, I see.
I see, I see, I see.
Oh, I'm wasting the rev on...
On these things, it's so funny.
Okay!
Skip cutscene.
Okay, lasers!
Yay!
Ouch, ouch, ouch!
Okay, onwards!
Why skip?
Because I already just saw it.
What are you talking about?
Oh, I don't like that.
Ouch, leap!
Leap!
They're... They're cycling around me.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I like their feathers, it's really cool.
I don't know...
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch!
Oh my god, they're all charging at me at once.
It's craziness.
When can I grab their shields?
Like, I don't understand when I can do that.
But sometimes I can, and...
I'm starting to lose it a little bit.
Starting to get lost in the sauce a little bit.
Oh, I'm doing it!
Kinda.
Oh my god, there's more!
My eyes are starting to blaze over a little bit.
Can you get him from behind?
But even that didn't do it, just them.
The yellow knights are immune to the shield though.
Ah, I see, I see.
Is this slow down time?
What is this thing?
It does!
Look at that!
It's a hourglass.
She got that hourglass bod, baby!
DMC takes up a lot of energy.
Key of Cronus.
Possesses a dense magical power needed to manipulate the very fabric of space and time.
BRB guys, I'm gonna go grab some water real quick.
Some water, water!
And then I will be back.
Also, I'm gonna get a pizza slice.
Because it's Friday!
And I made pizza.
And I'm gonna snack on it for a brief moment before we continue.
So, a short break.
I'll leave you with some...
With some...
What do you call it?
Devil May Cry ambiance.
Thank you, BRB.
Ev, I am back.
I'm back, but...
My cat's in here, so she'll probably...
She'll probably want out in like a second.
I'm scarfing it down.
This is a regular cheese pizza.
Nothing special.
My store didn't have anything special.
Let's dance on pineapple pizza.
I love pineapple pizza.
If you don't like it, I'll eat all of it.
Okay.
The device is incomplete, so it will only remain for a short amount of time while I'm in possession of the Kronos Press B near the Kronos Slicer.
We came from that side, so...
Nero, careful.
Oh, I need to go close to this thing?
I made it!
Nice!
Oh!
Oh, dang it.
I thought that was a statue.
Wait a second.
There is a statue in here.
Over yonder.
Over here?
Where?
I can't read the map at all.
Oh
no, we're gonna have to fight in here, huh?
There they are.
And after you guys, who will it be next, huh?
It will be after.
Why isn't this thing moving?
Hello?
Oh, there it goes.
It will be me!
Oh wow.
Oh no.
Wait, I saw a blower piece somewhere.
I lost it though.
I lost where it was.
Was it over yonder, over here?
Why do I keep saying yonder?
Like I'm from Prairie.
A little...
Ouch!
Even, oh, there's three of them.
Oh, that worked.
Whatever.
Oh, there it is.
Hi!
How do I get to it?
My brain is starting to go...
I was taking a sippy.
We're going through like the...
Oh my goodness.
Oh my gosh, we're going through like the whole...
Like...
Catalog of monsters here.
Wee!
Get
lost!
Oh yeah, use DT, you're so right.
What, that's it?
There's no more?
Oh, okay.
I thought there was one more.
Okay, sorry guys.
I ate my pizza so fast.
All right.
Run, run, run, run.
Oh, uh, run, uh, run, run, run, run.
Run, run.
We made it.
What about that blorb though?
I wonder how I was supposed to get it.
Pizza speedrun.
Nice.
Damn, we're killing it.
The first guys gave us health, but...
Like the clown guys, but...
Excuse me.
More?
Nope, just a dramatic death.
I do wonder about the blorbs.
I think I missed my opportunity.
It's so sad.
It's all right though.
Oh, wow, how kind.
Uh-oh.
That means there's gonna be a boss here.
Oh, wait, am I fighting...
Wait, I said find Kitty.
Am I fighting Mothman here?
Oh, no.
Yeah, we can buy the last blorb finally.
Yippee!
Oops, that's a victory.
Go back to the other side of the door for the blorb.
Really?
Wait, it says six out of six, but it'll let me buy it?
Are you serious?
I see no blorb.
Oh, it's gone again.
I hate chairs!
No, it gave us nothing!
How rude!
No way, there's nothing here?
No blorbs at all?
Oh boy, boss fight.
I should have bought some...
Maybe I should have bought some...
stars.
This is a hard fight.
He's as easy on you as I was last time.
If I have to kill you to save Kirie...
Let's roam!
Kirie!
Holy...
Oh, he's bug zapping.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, it's these guys.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, ah.
Dang it.
I think I missed my opportunity.
Yeah!
Yeah.
My strength what?
I'm just gonna do what we did last time.
Ouch!
Oh no!
What is he eating?
He re...
He healed.
Oh my gosh, no way.
How dare you.
I don't like this fight.
I don't like this fight already.
I have to avoid that 100%.
Oh my gosh.
Ah, I got him though.
Big damage.
No.
I'm not listening to you.
What the hell?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, I'm so dead.
This is it guys.
There's no way.
That's it.
Oh, you're so close.
Oh, I still got points though.
That's kind of nice.
Abandon all hope.
Wait, do I...
Did I actually?
Skill up.
Wait, did it...
It didn't refund everything, did it?
No.
Oh, wow.
Neat.
Good try though.
That was my first...
Well, no.
I did game over.
But I had the...
Maybe I get a...
I don't have enough for a gorb.
If I had enough for a gorb, I was gonna say.
That would have been the perfect spot for one.
Shoot.
Ah, that sucks.
Oh.
But...
I can buy...
A vital star.
I think I'll get a M vital star and then...
Um...
That should be enough.
You can DT out of the heal your...
Oh, I didn't see that.
Thank you.
I will try to remember that.
It's only 1,000 more.
Oh, I did buy it.
Okay.
Ouch.
No, we won't.
Your strength will not be yours.
Or my strength...
Is not yours.
I just like to have to make sure I have enough DT on hand, you know?
He's such a weenie.
Oh.
I'm just being really hyper-aggressive here.
I'm being like hyper-aggressive.
I know I gotta like get out of the way, but...
Oh my gosh.
Um...
It's definitely working.
Do you think if I DT, I'll heal enough?
Okay, it stopped.
Okay, it does not work in phase 2.
Star abusing?
Why?
How is it abusive if they're there to buy?
I think if you DT, you might kill him.
All right, let's try it.
There.
That might be it.
Hopefully...
Oh!
Nice!
I didn't have to use the star!
I was saving the...
I was saving the DT just in case I needed to get out of a grab, but I didn't have to.
God, they're so cool.
They're so cool looking.
The night demons, I love them.
They stole the girl!
GTA!
Damn.
Oh, damn.
Oh,
sorry.
My bad.
Oh my gosh.
What just happened?
Sorry.
No!
Yeah, baby.
No.
The necklace.
No!
She was wearing it!
She was wearing the necklace!
I give up!
Nero!
What rorbs did I miss?
Damn.
Yeah!
So then we got through two bosses today.
Awesome.
Good stuff.
Then I will end it here.
And we'll do the...
We'll see the cutscene next time.
Return to title screen.
Yes!
The game...
The game tested us with crashing.
I guess after a couple hours it crashes because it did that last time too.
Funny.
Lots of progress made today.
Yeah!
We're on 10 out of 20?
So...
Once we finish 10, we'll be halfway there.
Memory leak, maybe?
I don't know.
Possibly, right?
Hmm...
Four bosses?
Oh, that's right!
Because we took down...
Uh...
Credit card...
What's that guy?
Uh...
Don't tell me.
Cor...
Corbo...
What's his name?
Uh...
Kelly...
Don't say it.
Unless...
I'm not looking at chat.
Ca...
Not Kyle, obviously.
Uh...
Hmm...
I give up.
Caleb?
No!
What's his name?
Credo!
Was it cre...
Wait, was it Credo?
Did I get it right?
Actually?
Credo!
Code Vushi!
Thank you so much for the...
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Holy moly!
Wait, two?
Heck yeah!
Yeah, when do we get to see Lady and Trish?
Oh my gosh!
I'm just punching the heck out of Dante.
So funny.
Credit card...
And I mean, that was super fun stream.
Thank you!
Um, this is fun.
Uh...
I might be around later.
So...
Um...
If I see you, I'll see you.
Oh!
Um...
Yeah, we made good practice today!
Wait, so we bought...
We beat Snake Lady.
We beat Credo.
We beat Mothman.
Pizza!
What was the last one we beat?
Beat Mothman twice.
Oh, I guess yeah, that does count.
It was such an easy fight.
I don't even think of it as a bush fight.
Hehehehe.
No, I'm just kidding.
Um...
Yeah, that is four boss fights.
Wow, we're killing it, you guys.
Thank you so much!
This is fun.
I'll see you next week for more Devil May Cry 4.
Yay!
Oh, these are...
These are spoilers, maybe?
Well, spoilers, maybe?
I'm not looking.
Otsumita!
Thank you, guys!
Thank you, thank you!
Bye-bye!
Oh, we just saw that part.
Oh, wow!
Okay.
Yeah!
Bye-bye!